[Music]
Kobe Bryant's numbers have officially
been retired I want to say you know it's
thank you so much for tonight but you
know it's not it's not about my jerseys
that are hanging up there for me you
know it's about the jerseys that were
hanging up there before and without them
I couldn't be here today
the former Lakers star was honored
during halftime at Monday's game against
the Golden State Warriors his legendary
8 and 24 jerseys were retired joining
the uniforms of other famed Lakers stars
including Magic Johnson Kareem
abdul-jabbar and Shaq visibly emotional
Kobe took a moment to thank his wife and
three daughters who were all in
attendance it's about family it's about
my wife Vanessa thank you baby for being
an inspiration to me and and lastly our
daughters Natalia Gianna and Bianca you
know I hope that tonight is not you know
you guys know that you know if you do
the work you work hard enough dreams
come true it's not the destination it's
the journey as for how is nearly five
minute long speech ended by Kobe
announced that he was going to retire
with a poem back in November 2015 he
officially left the court the following
year
[Music]
you